it was not my choice to be standing here
today
i wanted to go to trial
i wanted to expose the criminality that
runs through the heart of this
corporation
a criminality demonstrated clearly and
irrevocably by the evidence which i have
seen
i wanted to share news group secrets
just as they have shared mine
unfortunately that legal recourse is not
available to me or to anyone who does
not have countless millions of pounds to
spend on the pursuit of justice
until someone comes along who can
confront the murdoch's endless means all
that i have left are these words and
they are the truth
as recently as tuesday afternoon lawyers
for news group attempted to get this
hearing adjourned
and to stop me and others from having
their statements read today
it is more than a little ironic that
they will go to such lengths to conceal
and protect their privacy
it was a practice that they would break
the law
it was a practice that they would steal
legally protected information
it is a fact that they stole my own
medical records and published that i had
had a pregnancy
and yet they continue to wage a war
against a legal enquiry into this
illegal and frankly disgraceful
behaviour
it is a part of my case that rebecca
brooks confirmed to those that represent
me that she knew about my pregnancy in
the most vulnerable moment of my life
it is a part of my case that she assured
those that represent me that she would
not print that information
and it is a part of my case that she the
son
did print that information
in these proceedings i learned firsthand
the extent to which that newspaper and
this corporation will go to protect
those at the top from being exposed and
facing the consequences of their actions
as my statement in open court made clear
i am deeply distressed and shocked by
what i have learned about the conduct of
journalists and senior management at the
sun and news international
they all thought they were above the law
i am sure when they weigh up the cost of
this case
that kind of behavior probably seemed
worth it bearing in mind the amount of
money they made by trading on people's
personal information
by trading on their lives by trading on
their own private truths in order to
sell their papers
they very nearly ruined my life i have
certainly seen how they have ruined the
lives of others
their behavior shattered me
damaged my reputation at times beyond
repair
and caused me to accuse my family and
friends of selling information that
catapulted me into a state of intense
paranoia and fear
their actions
their words their title tattle
compelled me into making decisions about
my future
and ultimately about my own body that i
have to live with every single day
i say this with humility and speak for
those who do not have a public profile
who do not have a voice to fight back
i stand here in fellowship with the
untold lives that have been destroyed by
the sun
and news international
i would love to not be in front of you
now having intimate details and personal
information yet again made public
but i feel i have a duty to illuminate
the facts as i have seen them
i want to thank my legal team for
working so tirelessly to take this as
far as we have
and it is my hope that others will be
able to pick up where we have left off
that somebody can take it further than i
was able to do
i would unhesitatingly participate as a
witness in anybody's effort to challenge
the people responsible at a trial